hoy vamos a hablar de un tema fascinante
cuando pensamos en áfrica es
prácticamente imposible abandonar los
numerosos fiches que sobrevuelan a
nuestro alrededor en ellos
áfrica parece siempre como una tierra
desolada atrasada catastrófica y
pérdidas desgracias hambre enfermedades
repúblicas bananeras guerras víctimas y
otros muchos sucesos copan por completo
a nuestra imaginación cuando pensamos en
este continente
sin embargo como afirmaba la isr
kapucinski sólo por el nombre geográfico
áfrica no existe para demostrar que en
esa tierra podemos encontrar lugares que
dejan atrás todos estos prejuicios hoy
nos vamos a desplazar hasta las
inmediaciones del desierto del kalahari
hoy botsuana es nuestro destino
imaginemos un país en el que solo
hubiese 22 universitarios un país en el
que sólo 15 de cada mil habitantes
supiesen leer y escribir un país del
tamaño de españa pero con sólo 20
kilómetros de carreteras imaginemos un
país cubierto por desierto y que no
tuviese salida al mar probablemente
nuestros augurios sobre el mismo serían
cuanto menos
poco halagüeños si además nos dijesen
que este país tiene problemas en el
abastecimiento de agua y electricidad
que depende de forma acuciante de la
ayuda exterior y que sus vecinos son más
bien hostiles y el panorama no
resultaría seguro de solomon estoy
convencido que ninguno de nosotros
apostaría al desarrollo de un país en el
que sólo hubiese en la práctica un
ingeniero y cuyas ciudades ni siquiera
estuviesen conectados por carretera
estoy convencido que prácticamente nos
parecería una broma así era botsuana en
1966 bien lo podríamos catalogar como un
inframundo de pesadilla y no en vano en
el momento es independencia era uno de
los diez países más pobres del planeta
a tenor de esta descripción estoy
convencido que todos podríamos pensar a
la hora de hablar de botsuana en decenas
de miles de niños hambrientos
deambulando en busca de comida o en unas
cuantas escuelas comandadas por
misioneros o cooperantes
sin embargo nada más lejos de la región
durante los últimos 50 años botsuana ha
sido uno de las mayores sorpresas
económicas del mundo ha sido unos países
con mayor crecimiento su propio interés
bruto per cápita en dólares constantes
ha crecido de forma anualizada un 59 por
ciento y esto es para que nos entendamos
se ha multiplicado por 15
pero es esta cifra alta o baja por
comparar durante el mismo periodo de
tiempo la misma cifra se ha multiplicado
en españa' por apenas 2 con 7 en bolivia
por 1.5 y en turquía por 3 con 1 si la
comparación la realizamos con los países
vecinos de botsuana el escenario no es
muy diferente incluso así que lo que
queremos es obtener en una radiografía
una instantánea de cuál es la situación
de botsuana actualmente en el ranking
internacional simplemente tenemos que
tomar datos del fondo monetario
internacional así si tomamos el fruto
interior bruto per cápita en parís de
poder adquisitivo y esto es y escribimos
los efectos frutos de los diferentes
índices relativos de precios nos
encontramos que botsuana se encuentra
por encima de países como brasil
colombia o tailandia sorprendente verdad
es cierto que este desarrollo económico
ha venido acompañado de una desigualdad
muy acuciante hoy botsuana es uno de los
países más desiguales de todo el planeta
pero no sería justo por otra parte
olvidar que dicho crecimiento económico
ha venido también acompañado de un
desarrollo muy importante los servicios
sociales que ha permitido excluir a la
mayoría de los habitantes de la pobreza
así hoy en día botsuana cuenta con el
mejor sistema educativo del áfrica sub
sahariana gratuito y universal tanto en
primaria como en secundaria el 95 por
ciento de la población tiene acceso a
agua potable y vive a menos de 8
kilómetros de un centro de atención
médica claro para quienes estamos
acostumbrados a un nivel de vida alto y
estos datos nos pueden resultar poco
sorprendentes pero tanto en áfrica como
los países más pobres no son algo
frecuente botsuana ha sido un éxito
económico pero también social pero que
ha pasado como ha logrado un país tan
pobre tan alejado de las cadenas de
producción internacionales y que además
no tiene salida al mar conseguir
semejante desarrollo parece casi un
milagro sobre todo si tenemos en cuenta
que este país ha sido durante los
últimos años terriblemente azotado por
el sida
no en vano botsuana es el segundo país
del mundo con mayor incidencia de vih
según las estadísticas de naciones
unidas y el 25 por ciento de su
población adulta
esto es una de cada 4 personas padecen
dicha patología
es cierto que en este boom económico en
los diamantes han jugado un papel
decisivo por suena es considerada la
mayor potencia del sector en el mundo
pero no es menos cierto que si no
hubiese contado con unas instituciones
estables e inclusivas nada de esto
hubiese sido posible son muchos los
casos seguro todos conocemos algunos de
países tremendamente ricos en recursos
naturales que sin embargo ven como su
población vive la auténtica miseria
países que son dirigidos por una élite
extractiva esto es una élite cuya única
motivación es perpetuarse en el poder
para esquilmar los recursos nacionales
que mejor ejemplo para un español que la
línea ecuatorial de td europea línea
ecuatorial que es un país muy rico en
petróleo es prácticamente un territorio
asentado sobre una balsa de petróleo sin
embargo esta riqueza no llega a sus
ciudadanos
y si como todos nos podemos imaginar sus
gobernantes están entre los más ricos
del mundo por contra en botsuana sus
autoridades sus líderes políticos pronto
dieron muestras de responsabilidad
así cuando se independizaron en 1966 y a
pesar de que los recursos eran muy
escasos como he dicho antes botsuana era
uno de los diez países más pobres del
planeta sus gobernantes apostaron por
una economía con impuestos bajos por
prohibir la nacionalización de la
propiedad privada para dar seguridad
jurídica y por evitar la mitad de lo
posible la emisión de deuda soberana
todo esto obligó a priorizar cada dólar
de gasto público
así por ejemplo las armas no fueron la
prioridad el gobierno de céret se calma
consideró que el ejército no era
prioritario y durante más de una década
botsuana careció de fuerzas armados si
no había dinero para sanidad si no había
dinero para escuelas mucho menos para
armas y soldados
de la misma forma tras la independencia
las autoridades buscaron la conciliación
entre la población blanca y la población
negra algo muy diferente a lo que
ocurrió por ejemplo en países vecinos
como zimbabwe precisamente en este
aspecto cabe destacar que el propio
seretse khama se haya casado en 1948 con
una mujer blanca ruth william y aunque
hoy esto nos pueda parecer algo normal
en aquel momento fue auténtica dinamita
política de hecho las autoridades
coloniales las autoridades británicas
promovieron prohibieron al matrimonio
acceder durante prácticamente una década
al protectorado se puede decir que
fueron exiliados por amor pero podemos
considerar acaso que todo el éxito se
debió a la elección circunstanciales
líderes políticos
esto es fue una cuestión de suerte donde
los ciudadanos de boston acertaron con
la elección de sus políticos lo cierto
es que más allá de esta coincidencia más
o menos fortuita o esta supuesta suerte
las instituciones personas se sentaron
sobre una tradición ya pre colonial de
corte pluralista
me explico además del tradicional poder
ejecutivo del poder legislativo y de la
necesaria independencia judicial en
botsuana existen también instituciones
tradicionales que refuerzan precisamente
la participación ciudadana y el control
de los poderes públicos así se encuentra
la casa de los jefes un órgano cuya
misión es asesorar al gobierno en
materia de leyes al gobierno en el
parlamento y sobre todo la que es
probablemente las el órgano político más
característico de este país la goat la
una asamblea donde los ciudadanos se
reúnen para debatir acerca de los
problemas y proyectos que afectan a la
comunidad una asamblea donde las
personas que intervienen tienen su turno
de palabra protegido y pueden intervenir
con plena libertad así no es extraño que
la gota no sólo haya permitido reforzar
la participación de los ciudadanos en él
en el futuro del país convirtiéndose en
un poderoso instrumento de participación
política sino que también es un órgano
de fiscalización de los poderes públicos
de las autoridades de los políticos por
ello no es extraño que en el índice
internacional de percepción de la
corrupción
botsuana cooper puesto 31 un puesto
mejor que el de países como españa bueno
seguro que a ninguno nos extraña israel
o taiwán por cierto en este aspecto cabe
también destacar que la democracia de
botsuana y ya la más antigua y estable
del continente africano
el resultado es evidente watson a un
lugar donde hasta hace 50 años no había
siquiera negocios formales y que padece
unas condiciones geográficas y
climáticas muy adversas es hoy el país
más rico el país menos corrupto y el
segundo país más libre del áfrica
subsahariana no ha sufrido guerra civil
o intervención militar alguna y el
crecimiento económico y el camino a la
prosperidad comenzó incluso antes de
descubrirse y empezar a explotar se los
yacimientos de diamantes la primera mina
abrió 172 y la época dorada no llegó
hasta la década los 80
para alcanzar el éxito el product
botsuano no necesita recurrir a
revoluciones populares ni a ningún tipo
de dictadura sino apostar pues
detenciones inclusivas sustentadas en la
democracia la pluralidad y el respeto a
los derechos de la propiedad
instituciones que guardan una
estabilidad macroeconómica se
comportarán de forma austera y
fomentarán el desarrollo de una pujante
economía de mercado así como la
inversión en la infraestructura esencial
para promover el desarrollo económico y
social
por delante son muchos los retos a los
que se enfrenta este país entre ellos
cabe destacar los siguientes en primer
lugar la diversificación de la economía
y la promoción de actividades intensivas
en mano de obra son puntos clave al fin
y al cabo el desempleo sigue siendo muy
alto y la pobreza continúa afectando al
20 por ciento de la población en segundo
lugar el desarrollo de infraestructuras
que mejoren su competitividad como el
ferrocarril y trans kalahari con la
gente la técnica moro por ebay y en
tercer lugar la atracción de inversión
extranjera y la privatización de
empresas públicas
los retos son muchos y el camino al
primer mundo es aún largo pero si algo
se ha ganado este país de poco más de
dos millones de habitantes es el derecho
casi la obligación a confiar en sus
posibilidades
estaremos muy atentos a las novedades
que ahí se produzcan y ese como puedes
ver más allá de las andanzas de nuestro
rey emérito con los elefantes y otros
seres vivos del lugar
botsuana resulta fascinante
utilizar una duda o qué es aportar algo
dejar un comentario